welcome to this video played in this
room master big guitar from Belgium who
is this Stefan docks yeah that's an IM
from hoops from belgium is some a player
who are in recent years made a big big
step forward rating wise he always was
around 2,300 and now he's close to 25
near Grand Master norm on area and yeah
I want against him I don't like maybe 15
years ago when a tournament game but as
mentioned he made a huge progress after
that ok on the zurich line of the of the
news oh the feature of my book and he's
taking lots of time him
a 3 is some I believe the best move v5
is also playable but then I have a 3 as
my main um recommendation because um I
think that the set up with not only
seven is some quite comfortable for
black it's not nothing spectacular but
it's some I think easier to play than
the Queen only 700 night on be aid to
really try to play g4
don't really believe that
but I'm trying to do is of course play a
form at a five a form yeah f5 preparing
that he doesn't really react to it in
any way which is some bit strange to be
honest I thought he needed to but okay
yeah okay this is certainly out okay for
white nothing terrible but thought you
would do some prophylactic rules
now I can take with the night
now it's a it's a simple solution then a
queen g5 and let me play on the F file
yes is it I don't know if it's really a
dangerous
hmm yeah this might on g6 it's something
it's a piece that can be improved maybe
age 69 f 8 h 7 f-6 something like that
c6 I don't don't mind and take there
should be six shouldn't be terrible
at least them I'm ahead on the clock
yeah don't want to play b6
hmm
mmm Queen a 3mp can't even play Queen a
32 bit strange but that's how it smooth
I to discern
I need to somehow coordinate pieces here
it's really uncomfortable
Roxy soon
it should reform try to play that now
but d6 is just hanging then very ugly
Brooke f6 second maybe and I cannot G
fri f Bishop g2 no I don't have it wow
this looks really bad
Oh yuck what a position
v6 is singing ha ha
unbelievably bad position we could have
taken d6 I mean this wins as well but
this was so maybe this wasn't stronger
so everything winds probably
okay Luke c7 was also interesting
ah
25 familia can our disco bishop of sun i
forgot about bishop of seven check time
warning
check
oh my god what did game I comply lost so
many moves and everything I mean this
this was was really comfortable for
black on the on the outset this I mean
if this is not not a good position then
you should discard this opening to the
dustbin but I really played it like a
complete [ __ ] for example of course in
this position why am I not playing b6
this is just the first of many many
weird things if i play b6 he cannot play
c5 and it'sit's nothing happening here I
must prevent him from playing c5 here
and now White has play yeah this is bad
just this and the thing is in this he
doesn't really have a great movie em
some I don't know maybe g3 or something
and then amongst other second I can just
I can block the Queen side and I have no
problem here because if let's say here
you can just I can just straight things
here here and this is just okay for
black I have a good structure my ship is
good it relates nicely to the pawn chain
and I can easily play along the FR with
no problem whatsoever in the game yet
the c5 c500 and I was immediately in
trouble around here of course I lost I
lost many moves but it was it was it was
annoying already okay thanks for
watching